Democrats are wetting their pants as
team Biden implodes anxiety is running
High among top party officials who think
the 2020 Playbook isn't going to work
again and that Biden's team may be too
confident in it Obama's former campaign
chair Jim Messina summing up sum it up
this way saying quote Democrats are
bedwetters historically they're like
just full-throated effing Panic sadly it
doesn't get much better for the
alternative Kamala Harris some Democrats
think it's too late to rehab the veep's
image but the media is giving it a shot
take a look at this tweet from USA Today
Republican attacks are hurting vice
president Kamala Harris approval rating
Democrats day and the White House is
running out of time to help her but how
many times do we have to remind them
that maybe it's just the way Kamala Acts
my mother used to she would give us a
hard time sometimes and she would say to
us I don't know what's wrong with you
young people
you think you just fell out of a coconut
tree
uh Greg so you are you have some
thoughts about the things she had to say
about coconut trees well I two questions
what is she on and where can I get it
I like you the best part about this is
like after she said that it was kind of
quiet and she went on she didn't care
there was like it was like it was like
when you tell a terrible joke on the
five uh which I know and she just rolled
right now but I I keep thinking maybe
she hates her job so much that she needs
a few cocktails I can't tell if she
needed a nap or medical attention or a
30-day stay at a spa but I know this is
sexist because presidents drink all the
time you know people get wasted you know
I I'm sure uh uh
I will be later but um this thing about
Democrats are wetting their pants I
didn't know what Joe had was contagious
but I think worrying is not a bad thing
and I think it would be a good thing for
Republicans to worry you might actually
do more things if you were worried you
might start thinking about things
earlier because you know the damage the
Dems are worrying that means they're
going to do something you don't want
them to do anything so Jessica I was
trying not to say the f word yeah I
struggled in the first place
but are you do you agree with Jim
Messina about Democrats being worried
about his my seat right here so that's
what that is the pooling at the floor
totally yeah when I was heavily pregnant
I actually was super nervous in my water
because Jesse had said he's like oh
it'll be fine I'll help yeah
um Greg's completely right this is what
about one part of it but this is what we
do and it's benefited us I mean going
into the 2022 midterms you could find
very few people even on the Democratic
side Simon Rosenberg is someone who
stands out
um who was saying we're going to be fine
here but everyone else was talking about
this Red Wave how bad is it going to be
we're definitely going to lose the
Senate and we're going to lose the house
by 10 plus seats 20 plus seats that's
positive Democrat thinking and then the
people were saying it's gonna be 40 or
50 points that we uh seats lost so I
would absolutely rather be running
scared about this and to try to Future
proof every single aspect of the
campaign that may be vulnerable and the
cook political report put out something
today talking about how if it is a
rematch and you know based on the Trump
Town Hall this week which I think you
know hurt him in the general but
certainly helped him in the primary and
Biden has announced that it is going to
be a rerun of 2020 and when you think
about how polarized our country is it
will be very very close again partisans
are partisans right and I'm not sure
that he will be able to he certainly
hasn't up to this point to move the
needle with those Trump 2016 voters who
then won for Biden in 2020 Biden really
outperforms him with Independence as
well as suburban women but yeah wet the
bed all the time Democrats you know we
need to be ready for a very tight
election so will you know there worried
about the playbook in particular because
they're just going to use 2020 in 2024
but the playbook for Biden was to keep
him in the basement not to have him out
they're still doing that with his White
House schedule but everybody else is
back at work like there's no excuse now
to be always working from home well I
also think that Playbook is played out
Katie because
I think 2020 to the extent that you can
put confidence in the outcome was about
a referendum on Donald Trump it wasn't
about Joe Biden nobody cast a vote in
2020 in support of Joe Biden they either
cast a vote for or against Donald Trump
and so then I began to think well the
camps are Made Who who is persuadable
who's different but I'll just share this
one story with you I was right there
hosting Fox and Friends we had a focus
group they were lined up right there and
interestingly it was full of Democrats
that morning and I got to tell you more
than a handful of people who said I
voted for Joe Biden would be willing to
now vote for Donald Trump and when
pressed as to why their answers were
about Joe Biden they weren't about all
of a sudden a conversion to love for
Donald Trump it was about a complete
rejection of the last three years of Joe
Biden so what I'm telling you is while
2020 may have been a referendum on
Donald Trump 2024 turns into a
referendum on Joe Biden and that should
cause them to wet the bed judge over to
you you know what
um 2020
um
I'm not quite sure how I compare it to
then but what I can tell you is things
are very different now if you think that
we were divided in 2020 in 2024 it's
worse than ever I think Americans are
more divided than ever I think what is
happening at the southern border and
honestly I am glad that the southern
Governors are moving the illegals into
the interior and into the Northeast so
the rest of the country can appreciate
what the South has been going through as
the Border has been invaded how much
we're going to spend in the social law a
safety net in Medicaid for people who
are not citizens and how much we're
going to lose for Citizens based upon
the the amount of the pot of money that
we have to begin with but even more than
that we've got an 80 year old president
who was clearly in cognitive decline in
80 in two more years I mean this guy he
can't even walk straight let alone
answer a question he can't answer the
Press course questions you know how is
he acting in World meetings and then we
hear about 10 million dollars going to
the Biden crime family the daughter the
lover the ex the this the that from a
Romanian corrupt guy who's got a company
from which that million dollars came
from all Chinese connected uh Chinese
party connected companies in Chinese
intelligence companies and then we've
got Kamala Harris right behind him I
don't know what she's on or what she
does but I'm telling you she's not right
and I don't want to hear that the
Republicans are mean to her and it's
just not fair you know what get out
there and belt one out that makes sense
so as Joe Biden is losing to blacks
Hispanics the moderates uh and to women
and Biden themselves the whole family is
losing I think it I think it's going to
be very different in 2014. and As Trump
runs to the cameras to talk to the media
Biden stays away from them so that will
also maybe cause a problem hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else